اخبار غزه بايجاز من تل ابيب اهلا بكم مع
دخول الحرب يومها ال وزاره الصحه تقول ان
الاحتلال ارتكب 12 مجزره في 24 ساعه
والامم المتحده تصف تصريحات الاسرائيليه
بنقل العمليات العسكريه الى رفح بالمقل
وبانها تشكل خطرا على اكثر من مليون ونصف
مليون فلسطيني امرتهم اسرائيل بالتوجه الى
هناك الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه نفذ اكثر
من 1500 عمليه اجلاء لجنود جرحى في معارك
غزه وذلك غداه اعلان كتائب القسام قتل 15
جنديا اسرائيليا من المسافه الصفر في حين
قالت سرايا القدس انها اوقعت قوات
اسرائيليه بين قتيل وجريح في اشتباكات
بخان يونس خلافات اسرائيليه بشان صفقه
التبادل والهدنه تهدد استمرار مجلس الحرب
وحكومه الطوارئ وتقارير تكشف ان نتنياهو
بحث مع مدير مكتبه السابق كيفيه تحييد
المعارضه من اليمين فيما يتعلق بصفقه
الرهائن التي بدات تتبلور وفي الضفه
الغربيه قوات الاحتلال تقتحم مدينه طوباس
ومخيم الدهيشه في بيت لحم وتوسع نطاق
اقتحاماتها في نابلس ونادي الاسير
الفلسطيني يقول ان الاحتلال اعتقل 12
فلسطينيا ليصل عدد المعتقلين منذ السابعه
من اكتوبر الى
6500 الى
اللقاء